[Music]
did you like scary stories as a kid or
you someone who was a kid did you enjoy
because some kids I've noticed my kids
don't like them at all
some kids love it and they're just up
for it right away where were you in the
spectrum I was it was just enforced on
me it was like I was brought up German I
am German raised as such you are you're
raised by in Germany German yeah German
know my mom's German and my dad's like
half German okay so there's this book
that I grew up on which was called
swiveled petah which is total page nice
yeah really nice and it's just basically
like cautionary tales for children in
which they all die your parents worked
we're like good night sweetie remember
the girl who played with matches burned
alive that's insanity actual like if the
image is like the kid who like sucked
his thumb his parents told them not to
so this little I don't know pixie man
runs by with like garden shears chopped
off his finger and there's blood and
he's like ah and the parents are like
the parents aren't even in it it's just
the child and the and the the person who
cuts their thumb off and the parents are
like the pranks are at the volkswagen
fact they've got stuff to do exactly
that's so great it's but it's also seems
it does seem sort of appropriate like
there are European
you know countries where you you find it
like the stories for kids are just so
brutal dark I think we actually found
does it say it's Stroup alweather what
is a little pate at Whoville painted oh
man is it real that's a real
illustration from strugle painter yet
and then this is the girl
the next image is great of this because
she's just ashes and the cats are crying
over her ashes are the cats they're
upset that she's on fire or sharing it
on the cat's act like they're at Burning
Man they're burning girl they're burning
girl yeah so they would read that to you
yeah yeah everything creaked in my room
too